Here's a thought.
If there was a prize for most screenwriting credits,...
...we'd have one of those "unfortunately, he can't be here with us tonight" moments.
That's because the winner, with over a thousand, is William Shakespeare.
But how can a man who died long before the invention of cinema...
...have racked up so many credits?
Simple. By creating the most moving, exciting and enduring stories ever written.
Shakespeare showed us what it means to be human.
We've all been lovesick or heartbroken like Romeo and Juliet,...
...or felt Macbeth's burn of greed and ambition.
And who hasn't experienced jealousy like Othello?
No wonder artists around the globe are still eager to adapt Will's works.
Yes, he may have died 400 years ago, but Shakespeare lives.